my best results could all have always
come from being very specific very
intentional and purposeful in designing
who it is that I want to know going and
meeting them finding anyone who can help
me meet those people and it might be a
type of person or might be a specific
individual and I just do that repeatedly
so it's not that I'm a social guy I like
meeting people I'm fascinated by people
they owe everybody has an amazing story
I want to hear it but at the end of the
day in earnest when I'm serious that my
career I can't interact consistently
with a thousand people or even 500
people so i need to find those dozens
max that i can interact with on a
regular basis and go deep as opposed to
having superficial exchanges you said
the facebook like is maybe not as
because we I think that step is over
rated I don't I personally have no idea
what a facebook like it's worth I know
it's widely debated and some people
think it's worth something other people
don't it's a sliding scale and that's a
metaphor I mean it's literally true of
that but it's true for all social media
we're questioning all the old standard
institutions arbitron Nielsen all the
rating systems the quantum CPM model the
advertising agencies the digital
agencies the media companies everybody
is trying to redefine what constitutes a
satisfying outcome how do we measure
that in today's world and that's why
dollars are trying to move up
traditional media into into other realms
and yet we're not really yet sure
exactly how to measure so the
transitions a little bit slower than it
then it might be I don't know the answer
you know I I mean branded entertainment
Saul fascinating phenomena a huge
opportunity to sandbox for people to
great you know creative people to get
work and do stuff that's that's really
cool but at the end of the day it's an
experiment right now and I think that's
true for a lot of things that I what
would I say about social media as in
business model I think you have to know
what your help desired outcome is and
use whichever platforms lead you there
most efficiently I believe in being very
efficient with your time I just started
using Instagram I just you know recently
and it's fabulous the amount of feedback
I get off that the number of followers
and whatnot it's it's really quite
stunning to me I tend to use Twitter
more than i use facebook now i find
twitter is more the nature of the dial
up the nature of that community and the
conversation is much more appropriate to
what i want to talk about where i want
to go facebook is a little bit sluggish
and it's more emotional and it's more
you know where i want to deal in a world
of ideas and shifts and changes and
opportunities and in creativity and
that's more Twitter for me so I think
you have to know what works for you
you